[Music]
so reason rage and revolution we're here
to talk about because for a long time
Britain has been incredibly politically
stable and chaotic government and
revolutions were the sort of things that
we saw in other nations but never here
but now our society is really fiercely
divided and each tribe is rigidly
certain of their moral rectitude and
that they're very reluctant even to talk
sometimes to their adversaries and with
the yellow vests bringing violence in
France as well this is something that's
not just happening here we seem to be
edging towards instability so how does a
culture rediscover harmony when it's
been so deeply divided and is it
possible that the UK could actually be
closer to large-scale social unrest
than we sometimes imagine so have
toleration and pluralism run their
course can we forge a harmonious future
after brexit if there is an after brexit
or our peace and stability just
necessary casualties when there's so
much at stake that's what we're going to
talk about today we have Vince Cable who
as you all know was leader the Liberal
Democrats coined the bollocks to brexit
catchphrase and I think led the Lib Dems
to their highest point in the polls
since the coalition Ellen Whelan who is
a political commentator at Speights
magazine and the author of what women
want fun freedom and an end to feminism
and aaron Bustani who is co-founder of
Navarra media which is a radical
left-wing alternative media organisation
and he's author of fully automated
luxury communism Aaron why don't you
start great I'd want to start with a
critique of the question itself because
its premise upon an assumption that
Britain has been a historically stable
society and of course this country had a
revolutionist civil war in the mid 17th
century 150 years before the French
Revolution more recently we have the
rise chart isms and movements for
democratic suffrage during the 19th
century the suffragettes
and of course we had a civil war
effective
with the Republic of Ireland sessions
the Free State only a century ago and
then more recently of course you've got
the miners strike you've got all grieve
you've got what happened with Murdoch on
and the press unions in the 1980s
immense social strife but where Mary is
absolutely right is that more or less
that was managed through political
institutions a lot of people were hurt a
lot of people saw their lives and their
way of life decimated but it didn't
descend into the things we would
normally think of as insurrection or
civil war it probably got closer than
many of us think but it didn't similarly
you have austerity since 2010 which
medical journal says that they're 120 to
130 thousand excess deaths which
correlate with austerity now we can have
an argument as to whether we might
caused it
we've got life expectancy falling the
average male from a working-class
background and Sheffield or in Glasgow
love 65 years that's when the tour is
now on sir increase the pension to 70 so
even within the present moment there's a
great deal of violence if you're on low
pay if you're sick life isn't
necessarily that good if you're in
poverty as a pensioner speaking of
excess deaths about 30,000 people die
every year that will excess deaths by
the civil service this is people that
die of the cold because of fuel poverty
and they tend to be older but of course
because we're not interested in
disrupting the status quo nobody calls
that what it is which is effectively a
form of social murder 30,000 people it's
a lot we're not talking about 10 or 20
people and yet we do nothing about it
why because it would disrupt the
economic orthodoxy and then I'll finish
with this the book I've written fully
automated luxury communism it's a bit
more pragmatic and practical than it
sounds and it's suggestions it starts
actually with a set of analyses which
probably on this panel we agree on I
think in the 21st century we are facing
several crises which I think our
existential to market capitalism
demographic ageing very difficult to
care for an aging population with a
market basis and climate change that has
problems with regards to geopolitics
resource scarcity has problems with
regards to mass migrations you have
automation and what that could do for
under an unemployment and then finally
you have what I would call basically the
continuation of the crisis we've seen
since two
2008 global financial crisis today in
the US 40 million people still use food
stamps it was 26 million in 2007 people
here are using food banks home ownership
in the u.s. is now its lowest level
since the mid-1960s home ownership
here's its lowest level since the
mid-1980s that's only going to get worse
so I think together that panoply of
crises mean that we are going to face
significant challenges to our democratic
system so either as a society we accept
the reality of those problems and we say
you know what we really need systems
change or yes I am very concerned that
things would become violent thank you
Thanks oh hello perhaps we're going to
be a difficult panel thanks I also want
to challenge the and the set up of the
debate but mainly the first sentence of
the blurb we talked about the fact that
for a long time Britain has been
politically stable I think we're
actually talking about the last 20 to 30
years and I'd say that rather than
stable actually it's been stagnant it
wasn't so long ago that we were having
debates about the kind of crisis of
apathy and politics and about what
Sterling's about out of touch
politicians but I think that what's
changed in the last three years and you
know what I'm talking about
and the B word that I'm not going to say
bollocks to it has meant that we've had
an incredible shift at kind of the
ground strip from underneath us and
everything has changed in British
politics I think that's a very good
reason to have tension to have
instability and perhaps have a running
series of crises about what it is that
we want British politics to do who we
want it to serve and crucially who
should be at the center of the power and
British politics and and I want to
challenge this idea of tension or
instability or change being a negative
thing actually think it's vital and I
think we've been crying out for it for a
very long time and it's something to be
potentially harness we can never go back
to the business-as-usual way of dealing
with politics the managerial
technocratic behind-closed-doors nature
politics has been stripped bare whether
that be through the braggart vote or
through the more importantly the
crashing of it by the political elites
we've had what someone I know has called
I think it's true the first stage of the
brexit revolution in which we have had
politicians laid bare for the views that
they hold we had called into question
the nature of our voting system the
sustainability of the House of Lords the
monarchy we've opened up a huge amount
of questions about what it is that
British democracy is and actually I
think we've been found wanting it's been
found wanting and it's weird to say
we're incredibly unsatisfactory timed
for the position of voters and ordinary
people's political power is an
understatement and so I think that the
second stage of the revolution which
might be where we start talking about
and the nature of unrest metaphorical or
otherwise I'm actually heartened by the
protests happening in Paris and across
France because I think that it shows
that there is very much still a
willingness of ordinary people to stand
up for the things that they believe in
to challenge their rulers and to
potentially open up a space where we can
have a discussion about what it is
society should believe in and what it is
that politics what shape politics should
take so I kind of challenge you to leave
aside any remaining cling that you've
got to the status quo any desire to
write why I'm back time whether that's
through voting arc and 50 or through
other aspects of politics and face the
perhaps uncomfortable fact for some of
you is that British politics is changing
and the people who are in charge of
British politics is changing and I think
that's a very very good thing
Vince yes I just want to address the
particular question about whether
Britain is now in a dangerously unstable
position and facing threat of violence
and I want to stir up a bit of
complacency I've been endlessly involved
in arguments with people on the other
side of the political side from me who
tell me that if we have another vote
brexit we couldn't possibly do it
because there would be massive eruption
of civil violence good civil war Theresa
May using that kind of rhetoric under
successes and I just think that is just
utter nonsense I think one of the reason
is we're confusing private and public
anger I mean I I my dad was a very
right-wing working-class conservative
who would now be in the brexit Party and
you know whenever president NASA or jomo
kenyatta was mentioned on the radio he
was sling the issues at it or take it
out on my mother but you know once he
stepped out to the front door he was a
model citizen and I think there is we're
confusing these two things and if you
look at the demography of the present
kind of brexit populism in Britain it
isn't leading the way to kind of
revolutionary violent change there are
two reasons first of all if you look at
the poorest cities in Britain contrary
to the narrative about austerity and so
on the poorest cities in Britain
actually voted to remain you know
Glasgow Dundee belfast Newcastle
Liverpool maybe Manchester they're not
richer and more crucially it was about
age the many correlates with voting
patterns but the overwhelming factor was
aimed for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you